at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half before my hands start shaking
this episode is brought to you by ascent
protein the cleanest least processed
protein I've ever consumed and I have
tried just about everything since well
before the 4-hour body I've started my
day with 20 to 30 grams of protein first
thing that has been part of my routine
but I don't always have the time or
necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal so what to do protein powders can
be a fast way to get this protein need
met but most products are full of crap
they're bleached they have excess sugar
terrible artificial sweeteners or just
straightforward low-grade low quality
protein Assent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent company is
actually cheese manufacturers so that
they produce their own native proteins
it's it's really fascinating and I've
looked at their processing it takes or
it took them about five years to develop
you can mix the protein in as little as
four ounces without any clumps or issues
of mix ability whatsoever and they
nailed the taste they tested for
instance there's the chocolate version
two hundred and eighty two different
versions they put a lot of money and a
lot of time into R&D for this particular
product if you love coffee they also
have a brand new cappuccino flavor which
is a variation I've enjoyed if you
prefer to test something outside of the
traditional vanilla or chocolate and
they have both way and my seller casings
so if you want to say
improve body composition and recovery
overnight slow release you can take the
micellar casein or in my case whey
protein I would take post-workout for
instance or in the morning so check it
out these guys are really fascinating
visit ascent protein dot-com forward
slash Tim that's a scen TPR OT
I n Commons like first descent going up
ascent protein comm /t Tim and you will
receive 20% off your entire purchase if
you want a very quick 20 or 30 gram dose
to start your day or after workout this
is a fantastic option it is arguably the
best that I've found so again check it
out
ascent protein comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs whether you need a logo custom
website app book cover or anything else
99designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as
possible I've used 99 designs for years
now I've used them for book covers some
mock-ups for the 4-hour body which went
on to become a number one New York Times
best seller illustrations of all
different types for the multi-volume The
Tao of Seneca which you can check out
and other graphic design projects for a
long time now and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers and illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it you should
check out some of my projects at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim I
really encourage you to take a look
because you will be impressed 99designs
comm forward slash Tim 99designs has
freelance experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the town of Seneca or you
can get concepts from multiple designers
and then pick your favorite so whether
you're starting a business or just
looking for extra design help resources
etc 99designs
has a solution right now you guys my
listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade
on your first design to check out your
first free upgrade please visit 99
designs comm forward slash Tim and click
the link on the landing page you can
also find their samples of projects from
you guys
listeners who have used 9mn designs for
logos apps even product packaging so
check it out 99 designs com forward
slash Tim
hello ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where each episode it is my job to tease
out the habits routines belief systems
decision-making frameworks whatever it
might be back stories failures and what
they've learned from them that you can
borrow from performers and apply in your
own lives in some fashion in this
episode we're gonna feature three guests
soman chainani Susan Cain and Graham
Duncan and I won't get into their BIOS
right now soman chainani was introduced
to me by brian koppelman some of you may
know as the co-creator of the hit show
billions as well as a filmmaker writer
director known for flicks such as
rounders the illusionist and the list
goes on and on Susan Cain speaking
myself as someone who considers himself
an introvert who can for short periods
pretend to be an extrovert what she
writes about is very very applicable to
my own life and Graham Duncan very
understated person who tends to stay out
of the public eye out of the limelight
and you may notice for those of you who
spotted the names all three of them are
featured in my latest book tribe of
mentors that Graham Duncan has no social
media profiles in the book and that
tells you a lot about Graham all three
of them
I should note share something in common
and that is that I would view all three
as people who are very very expert at
mitigating risk so I don't view them as
a throw caution to the wind risk at all
bunch whatsoever nonetheless they've
been very good at capping the downside
and making various career decisions and
bets that have paid off very very very
very large so I hope you enjoy this as
much as I did and I will let these three
brilliant guests take it from here
our guest today is soman chainani on
twitter at soman chainani som a n CH AI
n a n i on instagram at soman c or you
can find more about him soman chainani
dot net
somin is a detailed planner filmmaker in
Newark Times bestselling author his
debut fiction series the school for good
and evil has sold more than a million
copies has been translated into more
than 20 languages across six continents
and will soon be a film from Universal
Pictures a graduate of Harvard
University in Columbia University's MFA
film program someone began his career as
a screenwriter and director with his
films playing at more than 150 film
festivals around the world he was
recently named to the out 100 and has
received the $100,000
Shasha grant and Sun Valley Writers
Fellowship both for debut writers so the
right book can slip right inside of you
and somehow wake up the part of you
that's asleep it can actually put words
to the thoughts that your soul can't
quite get ahold of without at least a
little help and there's so many books
that have done this for me but there's
three in particular that I've read over
and over and over the first is the war
of art by Steven Pressfield which is
this slim tiny little book about the
creative process it's it's almost like
Tao teaching for artists that every time
you read that you go deeper and deeper
into this idea of overcoming the innate
resistance that faces anybody who wants
to make a change in their life
especially a creative one and every time
I read it it lights this crazy bonfire
inside of me that reminds me just how
far I have to go in order to trust the
creative voices inside of me instead of
the ego voices because that's the real
crisis with our creative work is that it
requires us to trust the silent voices
the ones that we actually you know don't
hear as loud as the positive and
negative ones that are always judging
the work that we do and it's easy to mix
all these voices up and end up quietly
abandoning your own ambition often
before you even start your project these
ego voices are also why I became a
pharmaceutical consultant at 21 years
old
Hawking viagra instead of writing
fantasy books and movie
like I do now because at the time a
pharmaceutical consultant felt like a
safe job the kind of normal job that you
tell your parents about and they tell
their friends about and makes you feel
like you're doing something right with
your life
and so these ego voices are also why I'm
afraid to date Ivy Leaguers I guess even
though I reluctantly have to admit that
I am one because when you go to an Ivy
League school you're tagged as a success
before you even accomplished anything
before you even know who you are and so
it Stokes this very fragile sense of
self and it makes you play completely
safe and ultimately to make any real
progress in my own life I had to
decondition myself from my own education
and really believe that I had nothing to
lose so yes pressfield's war of art
that's where I would say the yellow
brick road starts for a second book I
choose something unusual which is a
little life by hanya yanagihara which is
a whopper of a novel that tracks the
friendship of four male friends in New
York City over the course of almost 40
years you honestly won't find a book
more polarizing or divisive but to me
it's the greatest work of fiction I've
ever read primarily because it hits a
nerve that I've struggled with my whole
life which is that all of us have
baggage and wounds and pain that have
shaped the way we see the world but we
so often hide it or compartmentalize it
and because of that we close off parts
of ourselves and make our lives a lot
smaller a little life reminds us that
the pain we feel is shared and it's a
common human bond we shouldn't be
ashamed of it and that if we talk about
it and shine a light on it it's the
first step to becoming a whole person
instead of a fragmented one I honestly
can't imagine a more ambitious or
healing or moving book but what's also
funny is that a lot of people who hate a
little life and consider it the worst
book ever written
my brother despises it and he says quote
it's trash
basically the literary equivalent of
rubbernecking at a car accident so take
that for what you will Tim if any of
your listeners end up reading a little
life I'd be curious to hear which camp
they end up in and then I was thinking
for the third book given my profession
it made sense to think a little younger
because I honestly think the greatest
exercise you can do when you're stuck or
in a rut in your life is to remember
what your favorite children's book was a
book that you read over and over and
over again and never got tired of
because somewhere in that book is a clue
to not only what makes you tick but also
to your life's purpose my book was Peter
Pan which featured a title character who
is at once charming and also a complete
narcissistic pathological demon and I
think was that ambiguous space between
good and evil that I sparked to as a kid
and I'm now exploring for a living as an
adult what purchase of $100 were less
has most positively impacted your life
in the last six months or in recent
memory this is easy it's called mother
dirt it clears your skin and it cost $49
my skin was a hot mess for most of my
adolescence and into my 20s and when
skin problems follow you into adulthood
it's so frustrating because it becomes
completely demoralizing and it sykes you
out and it wreaks havoc on your
self-esteem and in my case I tried to
fix it with willpower which meant that I
tried every single product on earth I
tried antibiotics which kill your
stomach I tried harsh cleansers would
dry out your skin and really make
everything so much worse and then I was
trying every 3-step cleansing program
this side of Sephora which just left my
skin even more inflamed and wrung out
but then four years ago I discovered
mother dirt in a New York Times profile
back then I think it was known as a o+
biome and their theory was super simple
it was that skin naturally needs a OB
which is short for ammonia oxidizing
bacteria in order to stay healthy and
clear but soaps creams and all the
things we use to help our skin end up
killing all that natural bacteria so if
you stop using those products and
restore that bacteria naturally then all
of a sudden your skin goes back to its
normal healthy state so my brain
instantly connected with this I was like
yes this makes sense I want to try this
so I wrote them begging them to become
one of their beta testers and luckily
they agreed and mother dirt came in a
little spray bottle which I kept in my
fridge
and within a week of using it my skin
was really completely clear and I've
been using it for four years every
single day the trick to making it work
though is not to use other products
that'll kill the bacteria while you're
using mother dirt mother dirt literally
becomes your routine so I threw out all
my fancy zits at being poor unclogging
oil and chiming microderm we promise
this will make you look like natalie
portman creams and toners and cleansers
all of it and it was really the best day
ever
and all I do now is spray my face twice
a day with mother dirt I don't use
anything else it's that easy
their website is mother dirt comm and I
have tons of experience with this
product so your listeners should feel
free to shoot me questions if they have
any of them if they want to try it or if
they're using it how has a failure or a
parent failure set you up for later
success do you have any favorite failure
of yours oh this story hurts to tell I
don't know if I've ever told it the
biggest failure I ever had was with my
thesis film at Columbia's Graduate Film
School a movie I'd poured all my savings
into at that point about $25,000 and
worked on for eight months and a day
before my final showing to the faculty I
suddenly got a really bad case of cold
feet and there was a reason for this
which goes back to what I said earlier
about Ivy Leaguers and fragile egos
Columbia film school had this diabolical
little system which I don't even know if
they still have today but after the
first year the faculty all got together
and gave out this one big cash prize I
think it was sixteen thousand dollars to
whoever they thought was the most
promising director I ended up getting
that prize which ended up being a lot
more of a curse than anything since it
directly led to the failure that
happened next so with my thesis film I
wanted to prove so badly that I deserve
that prize that I was the most promising
director that they put their faith in
the right student so the night before my
jury showing you know instead of being
content with all the work I put into
that film I completely panicked and
decided I should show it to one of the
professors on the jury hoping that he'd
reassure me
he didn't he thought it was slow and
quote feckless that word still stings
anytime I hear it or read it and
recommend it I slash the whole movie to
pieces and make it half the length
instead of looking for a second opinion
or balancing his feedback against my own
thoughts of my work I panic like I was a
headless rooster this professor was
obviously on the jury and I wanted to
stay the faculties blessed son and so I
trusted external validation at this
point in my life more than my own
creative compass so like a lemming I
followed his advice I spent the whole
night undoing eight months of work and
recutting the film and the next day I
presented it this hacked-up Frankenstein
to the faculty who absolutely demolished
it they literally thought it was the
worst movie in our class probably one of
the worst movies they'd seen you know
come into the the thesis presentations
all credibility I'd earned over the past
three years went up in smoke
I wasn't invited to participate in the
public film school festival lots of
gossip about how I never should have
gotten that scholarship floating around
how I had no talent how I'd let the
prize get to my head and of course it
did just not in the way that they all
thought a few weeks later I ran into one
of those disappointed faculty members
one who'd been a huge supporter of my
work before this and now could barely
look at me I told him the story the last
minute recutting
I'd done the night before my
presentation and he asked me if he could
see the original version so I showed it
to him and I just remember the way his
eyes kind of lit up like stars and he
said ah there you are now I see you
incidentally that short film in its
original version went on to great
success and it started my whole career
but here's the lesson that I you know
remind myself of constantly and I hope
you can take away from it which is that
don't let someone knock you off your
course after you've put in all the work
you have to trust the work you've done
you have to always trust the work if you
could have a gigantic billboard anywhere
with anything on it what would it say
and why if I was in Hollywood the
Billboard would say they're lying and
actually have to remind this to myself
all the time every time I'm on a call
with a Hollywood producer or stood
studio executive I actually pull up a
screen saver with those two words
they're lying
in all caps and I watch it sort of
spread across the screen during the call
over and over and it makes the whole
experience a lot more productive and
less frustrating this reminds me of my
first experience in Hollywood I was
coming out of film school I'd written a
script that a lot of producers and
studios were interested in and at my
first ever studio meeting the exact
sweeps into the room crows it's the best
script that he's ever read and he's like
kid we are making this movie and he
slams his fists on the table after that
meeting I never heard from him again and
yeah obviously he didn't make the movie
but I think it's a depressing billboard
to focus on Hollywood's lies so let's
pick another one if I'm anywhere but LA
the Billboard would say if you can
conceive of it it's probably wrong and
years of meditation taught me that most
of the ideas and opinions and rules and
thick systems I have in my mind those
aren't the real truth they're the
residues of past experience that I
haven't found a way to let go of and to
be open to life to be truly ourselves
it's our job to be aware only aware not
to clutter that precious awareness with
judgments so I need meditation as my
primary weapon to survive life to let me
study my own brain like a detective
looking for thoughts or thought patterns
that I can let go of because the secret
to happiness I've learned isn't really
happiness at all but cultivating silence
inside of me this this big blank
beautiful space and the only way I know
how to make more blank space is through
meditation so 20 minutes a day every day
wherever I am often I use a headspace
app because it logs your progress so it
gives you a little bit of an incentive
to keep a streak going but all you need
is a comfortable chair and silence and
meditation becomes the portal to the
rest of my day what is one of the best
or most worthwhile investments you've
ever made
oh it's definitely flying trapeze
lessons those are like shock therapy for
the Soul because as soon as you get on
the platform for your first class it's
50 feet high and so you're instantly
making all these cerebral calculations
you're like I'm gonna jump this way and
then I'm gonna do this and then my legs
are gonna go over the bar here and I'm
gonna drop into the net there and it's
all complete and utter BS because once
you jump off the platform you realize in
an instant that you have two choices
either you trust your body or you die
and for someone who makes a living with
my head I need that kind of primal
therapy to really integrate with my body
you know in a very sort of forceful
violent way and just one class maybe
realized that underneath my mind's
chatter my body actually has everything
under control if I'm willing to just you
know take the plunge and fly this
reminds me of a related story which is
that I'm a compulsive crossfitter and at
first my favorite skill when I started
the classes was box jumps it felt so
controllable that if you just jump on a
box of a certain height and you clear it
you get to build the box higher and try
again
it was linear was Pavlovian and rewards
a control freak like me in the clearest
possible way but at some point I hit a
plateau and I couldn't jump any higher I
got frustrated I tried to will myself
higher I was watching youtube videos all
day trying to find out like what I was
doing wrong and it just led to me
forcing it again again and again and
compromising my form and wiping out a
lot and you know no matter how much I
grit my teeth and did it again and again
I couldn't get past my max of 42 inches
so I finally said that's my max I told
my trainer Dave I said the 42 inches
that's it that's my complete Max and he
disagreed
he's like you've gotten to this height
by jumping anyone can jump you can
control a jump but the only way you're
going to get any higher is by flying and
you can't think your way through flight
so I had to relearn box jumping to get
past my self-imposed max my cerebral max
and find my real maximum and this
required the same trust in my body as a
trapeze did jump commit let the body do
the work and if there's one thing you
can take from this it's
you can find something in your own life
that forces you to have this experience
jump commit let the body do the work
with there's trapeze lessons or an
improv class or just freestyle dancing
in your room to Rihanna
let your body show you its natural
intelligence give it the chance to show
you it's gonna be the most intimate
experience you ever have with yourself
what is an unusual habit or an absurd
thing that you love I feel like this is
a guilty pleasures question and I have
so many of those everything from Celine
Dion to peanutbutter slaughter popcorn
to the movie showgirls to that horrible
TV show Alf
but here's one I guess that's more
important to me which is and I'd it's
not something I confess regularly but
every night before I go to bed I pull
out old issues of Archie comics and read
them it's not a new habit I used to read
Archie as a kid before I went to bed
back then also and it's because
Riverdale's in the comic always seems so
crisp and bright and welcoming River
there was a complete opposite of the
kind of school I went to which always
felt so dark and morose and always made
me feel scared somehow before having to
go there on Monday mornings and so just
reading the Archie comics gave me this
soothe the little soothing warm feeling
before I drifted off to sleep but I
still get to this very day when I read
them but maybe more importantly closing
the day by reading the same thing I did
when I was younger gives my life this
sense of perfect order somehow maybe
there's a deeper lesson in this also I
know I'm technically a writer of young
adult literature but I never think of my
audience that way or I never think of
myself as a writer for kids because I
think the things we love when we're
young or still the things we love when
we're older we just forget or we give up
or we quote grow up and that's why the
old fairy tales always held so much
power for me because they worked for
everyone young or old it didn't matter
who you were just like Archie works for
me young or old and so maybe we all grow
up in body one day but I'm not
our soul ever does and that's why the
best story somehow can touch us all and
transcend things like age or nationality
or culture or anything like that that's
why the best stories are universal in
the last five years what new belief
behavior or habit has most improved your
life I know I should offer her something
deeply profound here but honestly the
thing that's most improved my life in
the last year is unfollowing hot people
on Instagram there's this amazing short
story by Ted Chang that started all this
called liking what you see that did a
real number on me the story of search
that beauty has become this kind of
alien modern-day super drug that with
filtered and facetune social media and
retouch models on ads and and porn so
easily accessible we've completely
overloaded the senses and overstimulated
ourselves so that our natural instincts
can no longer recognize or react to real
beauty anymore and that's making us
confused and miserable both in how we
judge ourselves and also how we judge
others and that crystal-clear warning
that beauty is literally ruining our
lives like the worst drug woke me up
because if we're not careful and this is
where I fell into this trap and was
completely guilty of it our social media
feeds become filled with people we
follow only because they're beautiful or
because we're envious of their lives
and without really realizing it your
feed turns into this torture device an
assault of beauty and perfection
designed to make you feel inadequate and
so opening up Instagram doesn't inspire
inspire you anymore it just makes you
start to hate live your own life since
you can't possibly measure up to the
gods and goddesses of all these
perfectly filtered pictures and it makes
you intolerant of other people's real
imperfections and then it makes you
start to despise the weight of real
people and real life and invest in
shallow flimsy kind of 2d mirrors of it
it makes you constantly judge your own
life against others it makes you
fragment your own consciousness because
you're living outside of your own life
in order to get the perfect picture of
it it's completely and utterly deadly
and so I would say you have to use
social media to make yourself better to
make yourself feel better not to punish
so and that honestly has been the most
valuable change in my life in the last
couple years what advice would you give
to a smart driven college student about
to enter the real world let's start with
the advice that I'd give which is make
sure you have something every day that
you're looking forward to hopefully it's
your job but if it's not which is a
completely universal and understandable
condition maybe it's a basketball game
after work or a voice lesson or your
writing group or an open mic night maybe
it's a date have something everyday that
lights you up because it'll keep your
soul hungry to create more of these
moments instead of getting dragged down
into kind of the rut of having you know
a job that you're not excited about and
I'll also remind you what really
fulfills you in life when I was a
pharmaceutical consultant and I was
completely miserable I used to come home
from work and work on my novel that
would eventually become the school for
good and evil I never intended to
publish it I never intended anyone to
read it I just did it to offset the
misery of a job that I hated
and over time I loved writing the book
so much that I used to leave early
sometimes in order to work on it and
slowly the work started to you know the
the novel starts take over my work life
- I found myself secretly working on it
you know in the mornings during meetings
in the corner during office during the
lunch and eventually I got fired because
they figured out I wasn't doing any of
the real work and I was actually working
on my book and the truth was I wasn't
upset because I discovered what had made
me happy at that point which was telling
stories and nothing was gonna put that
genie back in the bottle ask for advice
I'd ignore a little part of me dies
every time someone tells me that they've
taken a job as a stepping-stone to
something else when they clearly have no
interest in that job whatsoever and I
think it's because the truth is you only
have one life to live time is super
valuable it's the one currency that
we're all fighting to get more of and so
if you're using the idea of stepping
stones and jobs that you're not really
interested in to get somewhere else
you're probably relying on somebody
else's path or definitions of success
that was created in the past and I think
it's more important to live in your own
present
and try to make your own path it's gonna
end up being more fulfilling for your
own life what are bad recommendations
that you hear in your profession or area
of expertise I think too often aspiring
artists put this pressure on themselves
to make the creative work their only
source of income that they can't be an
artist unless they're a full-time artist
somehow and in my experience it's just a
road to complete another misery because
if art is your only source of income
then there's unrelenting pressure on
that art and mercenary pressure isn't
just the enemy of the creative elves
inside you trying to get the work done
but mercenary pressure also often leads
to really bad and rushed work so having
another stream of income drains the
pressure on your creative engine if
nothing comes of your art or it flops
miserably
whatever you still have an ironclad plan
to support yourself and so your quit if
soul feels a lot lighter it feels free
to do its best work and I'm still a
personal practitioner of this even
though I could easily be you know
full-time writer because after four
books in a movie deal I want a separate
side stream of income in order to be
able to write without feeling like it's
a matter of life and death
so I tutor kids on the side I help them
with their college applications and I've
been doing that for the last 10 years
and really no plans to stop because it
makes the books better in the end if I
don't feel like the books are my only
source of livelihood in the last five
years what have you become better at
saying no to I'm convinced that the
reason Hollywood movies are often so
terrible is because everyone is so busy
hedging their bets that they're working
on a thousand projects at once they
don't want to commit to anything for
fear that it's gonna fail no one is
giving anything in their full focus so
when I worked on the school for good and
evil I decided to take the opposite
track I decided to commit completely and
the series has taught me to be patient
because when I'm writing a new book
that's all I work on and I say no to all
other creative projects no matter how
lucrative do I miss opportunities
absolutely but it means that when the
books hit the shelves I know that I've
left everything on the page and they're
the absolute best I could have done
which then gives a series the greatest
chance to survive through
time it's easier to say no that when
professionally I know what my driving
need is because if you're driving you
this to build income and provide for
your family then you'll say no to
anything that doesn't further to that
goal but if your driving needs to have
your own business for example then you
need to be a bit more promiscuous and
trying out ideas until the right one
hits in my case my driving need is
always unequivocal which is I want to
make something that lasts and that means
committing to my current work like a
marriage and believing that if I give
these six books in the series everything
I have then better opportunities will
eventually rise to replace the ones that
I passed up when you feel overwhelmed or
unfocused what do you do so feeling
overwhelmed usually means one of two
things either my Bloods trapped in my
head and I need to get out there and
exercise and move the blood around and
you know give myself space to breathe
well more likely my to-do list has
become completely over packed and my
brain no there's no way I can reasonably
get done everything I've set out to do
and so that's when the solution is
taking out the calendar and start
cancelling things moving things around
you know seeing what I can take off my
plate and then I can feel the paralysis
evaporate once I've hit that threshold
of knowing that I can reasonably
accomplish whatever I want to do now
feeling unfocused is all different
because it usually means I haven't quite
locked in to whatever I'm working on
that a part of me still thinks I can
pull the ripcord and bail and is afraid
to commit it usually happens in the
first three months of writing a new book
because that lack of focus is usually
just fear fear that the new book is
terrible fear that it's going to fail
miserably and sink my career early on I
used to give in to that fear and for
books later now I know that I just have
to hold on tight grip my teeth and blow
right through it like a ghost our guest
today is Susan Cain CAI n on Twitter at
Susan Cain Facebook author Susan Cain
quiet rev.com is her website susan is
the co-founder of quiet revolution and
the author of the bestsellers quiet
power subtitle the secret strengths of
introverted kids and
quiet subtitle the power of introverts
in a world that can't stop talking which
has been translated into 40 languages
and has been on the New York Times
bestseller list for more than four years
straight quiet was named the best book
of the Year by Fast Company magazine
which also named Susan one of its most
creative people in business Susan is the
co-founder of the quiet schools Network
and the quiet Leadership Institute and
her writing has appeared in The New York
Times the Atlantic The Wall Street
Journal and other publications her TED
talk has been viewed more than 17
million times probably more than 20
million at this point and was named by
Bill Gates as one of his all-time
favorite talks how has a failure or
apparent failure set you up for later
success do you have any favorite failure
of yours so a very long time ago I used
to be a corporate lawyer and I was a
very ambivalent corporate lawyer and
anyone could have told you that it was
in the wrong profession but still I had
dedicated tons of time to it you know
three years of law school one year of
clerking for a federal judge six and a
half years at a Wall Street law firm and
I had a lot of very deep relationships
with fellow attorneys but the day came
when I was very well along on
partnership track that the senior
partner in my firm came to my office and
sat down and told me that I would not be
put up her partner on schedule and to
this day I really don't know whether he
meant that I would never be put up for
partner or just delayed for a long time
but all I know is that I burst into
tears right in front of him and then
asked for a leave of absence and I left
work that day and I remember bicycling
around and around Central Park in New
York City having no idea what I was
going to do next I thought I'd probably
travel and I had all kinds of plans to
go to India and so on but instead and
and this all happened in such a kind of
sudden and cinematic way that it will
defy belief but what happened is I
remembered that I had always wanted to
be a writer which seems strange you
would think I had always had that in the
back of my
but my writing dreams were something I
know forgot about had forgotten about
for a very long time but I started
writing that very night and then the
next day I signed up for a class at NYU
and creative nonfiction writing and the
next week I went to the very first
session of that class and it really was
like a kind of epiphany moment I felt
like I was finally home I had no
expectation of ever making a living
through writing because you always hear
about how difficult that is but I was
just clear to me that from then on I was
gonna put writing at my Center and so I
decided to just look for freelance work
that would give me lots of free time to
to feed my hobby now if I had succeeded
at making partner on schedule I might
still be there today you know kind of
miserably negotiating corporate
transaction 16 hours a day it's not that
I had never thought about what else I
might want to do other than law but
there's something about being inside a
very intense 16 hour a day hermetic
culture like a law practice that makes
it really difficult to figure out what
else you might want to do what is one of
the best or most worthwhile investments
you've ever made best investment I ever
made was the 7 years of time that it
took me to write quiet I really didn't
care how long it took and though I very
much wanted the book to succeed I felt
good about that investment of time
regardless of the outcome because I
really didn't know what was gonna happen
but I felt so certain that writing in
general and that writing that book in
particular was the right thing to do so
what happen is well first of all I had
two kids along the way so of course that
slowed me down but also I handed in a
first draft after the first two years
and my editor basically said this is
very crappy and and she said take all
the time you need and start from scratch
and go home and get it right and you
might think that that was a moment of
grand discouragement but it was actually
exactly the opposite I I remember
leaving her office elated because I
agreed with her and I
knew I needed a lot of time to get it
right and I was thrilled that the
publisher was giving it to me
you know I had never published a word
before quiet and I felt like I was
learning how to write a book from from
scratch and most publishing houses rush
books to market a long time before
they're really fully done you know just
because of economic exigencies and and I
feel like if she had done that there
would be no quiet revolution what is an
unusual habit or an absurd thing that
you love I really love sad minor-key
music and the funny thing is I find that
kind of music
very elevating and transcendent and not
actually sad at all and I think it's
because this kind of music is really
about the fragility and the preciousness
of life and love so if you're curious
about some examples for me Leonard Cohn
is my patron saint
you could try listening to dance me to
the end of love or to famous blue
raincoat or pretty much to anything that
he's ever written if you're not familiar
with his work
I'm sure you know his song hallelujah
that has been made into a cover a
gazillion times but that really is only
the tip of Leonard iceberg I also love
this song called he Nakia foul by an
amazing guy named Eden rifle it's a
really gorgeous song of a man longing
for his beloved and it's really about
longing in general whether longing for
God or for heaven or whatever my
favorite word in any language is the
word so da G which is the Portuguese
word that's at the heart of Brazilian
and Portuguese culture and music and it
basically means a kind of sweet longing
for a beloved thing or person that will
likely never return to you and I know
that sounds thanks they're desperately
sad but again that it's so hard to
articulate it but there's something so
incredibly beautiful and transcendent in
that very idea and if you want to hear
music expressing that idea you could try
called mod radius or the singer Caesarea
I'm not sure I'm pronouncing her name
correctly but Caesarea Evora something
like that and by the way my my next book
or my whole kind of next work chapter in
my life is all about this topic of of
how loss and longing are such an
essential part of love and art and
growth in general what advice would you
give to a smart driven college student
about to enter the real world smart
driven college student you're gonna hear
so many stories of people who risked
everything in order to achieve this goal
or that goal especially when it comes to
creative goals but I don't believe that
your best creative work is done when
you're stressed out because you're like
on the edge of bankruptcy or some other
personal disaster it's really just the
opposite so you should be setting up
your life in a way that's as comfortable
and happy as possible and that often
means setting it up in a way that
doesn't appear very creative on the
outside because you're you're tapping
into kind of a more conservative
structures but what you're really doing
is freeing yourself up to accommodate
your creative work so I often ask myself
whether all those years of Wall Street
law were a waste
given that what I really was meant I
think to be doing the whole time was to
explore human psychology you know do
what I love to do now writing about what
it's like to be alive it's really how I
think of my work but the answer is that
no it was totally not a waste for so
many reasons I mean first of all because
I learned so much about the so-called
real world that would have otherwise
been a mystery to me and second because
a front-row seat at a Wall Street
negotiation is as good a place as any to
study the ridiculousness of being human
but most of all maybe is because it gave
those years that I spent practicing law
gave me a financial cushion when I was
ready to use it to try out a creative
life it wasn't a huge cushion I had not
managed to save that much but it didn't
make a huge difference so
even once I started my writing life I
spent tons of times setting up this
little freelance business on the side
where I taught people negotiation skills
and it was something that I felt I could
use as long as I needed to to support
myself when my real center always was
writing and I the thing I was trying to
do the whole time was take the pressure
off the writing so that the writing
could always be a source of joy and
satisfaction so I told myself that my
goal was to get something published by
the time I was 75 years old and that was
it
so I met my goal a lot earlier than that
okay so I am NOT saying by the way that
the smart driven college student who
wants to have a creative life should
spend ten years in corporate finance
first very much not saying that I'm
really making a more basic point that
you should just be planning how you're
gonna make ends meet and have a way to
do that and that way the time that you
do spend on your creative project and it
could be 30 minutes a day it could be 10
hours a day but you want those moments
to be about focus and flow and
occasional glimpses of joy and you do
not want them to be associated with
financial stress when you feel
overwhelmed or unfocused what do you do
I love espresso I would happily consume
it all day long but I'm really afraid of
habituating to it and losing its magic
powers so I only allow myself to have
one latte a day and I save it for when
I'm doing my most creative work of the
day because it really does jumpstart my
mind and it's almost magical it has a
kind of magical power and also by now I
associate latte and a kind of Pavlovian
way with writing which then gets
associated in a Pavlovian way with the
pleasure of coffee so it's all a really
good feedback loop
my guest today is Graham Duncan you can
find out more about him at East Rock Kap
c.a.p com
Graham is the co-founder of East Rock
Capital an investment firm that manages
two billion dollars or so for a small
number of families and their charitable
foundations before starting East Rock
twelve years ago
Graham worked at two other investment
firms he started his career by
co-founding the independent Wall Street
research firm medley Global Advisors
Graham graduated from Yale with the BAA
ethics politics and economics he is a
member of the Council on Foreign
Relations and serves as co-chair of the
Sun Conference Foundation which funds
pediatric cancer research our mutual
friend Josh Waitzkin who introduced us
and you should look up Josh Waitzkin if
you don't know who he is
I'll give you a hint searching for Bobby
Fischer Josh calls Graham quote the tip
of the spear in the realms of talent
tracking in judgment of human potential
in high-stakes mental arenas end quote
that is a mouthful but Graham as I've
gotten to know him over the years is
more and more impressive with every
encounter that I have with him and if
you want to hear more from Graham ideas
his thinking frameworks everything you
can sign up for his monthly email
newsletter at Graham Duncan dot blog
what is an unusual habit or an absurd
thing that you love so Tim I wear the
sub pack wearable physical sound system
while I commute on the subway to my
office and sometimes I wear it while I
work in my desk you strap the system to
your back and chest and I'll let you
feel the vibration of music through your
whole body music producers gamers and
deaf people are the primary users and I
find the full body experience of music
makes listening to music or even a
podcast that has a lot of bass more of
an immersive somatic experience rather
than just a conceptual head thing if you
could have a gigantic billboard anywhere
with anything on it what would it say
and why so I have two candidates first
it's not how well you play the game it's
deciding what game you want to play
that's by Kwame abia who's a philosophy
professor at NYU and I like it because
it separates striving from strategy it
reminds me to take a macro view of
whatever I'm doing
like in a video game where you can zoom
out and you suddenly see you've been
running around in a one corner of the
maze it loosens my relationship to the
game too it's kind of it's the game of
the game helping to separate having
ambition from being ambitious or
accessing hustle without actually
becoming a hustler another quote that I
really like is from the Buddhist
novelist George Saunders who said in an
interview with The New Yorker that he
has an image of people's nectar in
decaying containers Buddhists like
Saunders think everyone has a Buddha
nature that good core of your being
people sometimes lose track of it but
it's there and I think it's such a good
assumption to have about everyone even
if you're wrong sometimes that that's
there and I also love that image of
nectar and decaying containers that
helps me visualize the stream of Buddha
nature flowing through all the lovely
flawed living and slowly dying creatures
that we all encounter every day and
sometimes get this glimpse of how my
three-year-old daughter's three-year-old
self is so temporary Buddhists like to
say we're all on fire and it's so
beautiful sometimes TuneIn just see the
flickering what are one two three books
that are greatly influenced your life so
the psychiatrist Sam Braun des has a
book called making sense of people
that's had a huge impact on my thinking
and I sometimes give up a copy to people
who are building a new team and doing a
lot of hiring or even a friend that
might be deciding whether or not to get
engaged as part of my role as an
investor I interview four to five
hundred people a year to decide whether
to hire them or invest in their various
startup to investment funds the most
useful mental model I've found to help
understand helped me understand what
makes people tick is the one that
Brandis describes eloquently in his book
the model is called the big five or
ocean and the oh stand for open-minded
the C stands for conscientious the e for
extroverted a for agreeable in for
neurotic and the academics academics who
developed the model clumped every
English adjective that could be used to
describe somebody in two categories and
then they reduce them to a smallest set
of factors as they could
so if lots of people agreed they could
call somebody both gregarious and
outgoing and they decided that was the
same thing and they kept reducing that
down until they got say extraversion as
a primary factor and in the academic
literature on personality the big five
is like the equivalent of gravity there
have been thousands of studies and it's
considered much more statistically
accurate than alternative such as my
restricts and so if you want to picture
it like four hi open-minded picture
Leonardo da Vinci for a high
conscientious picture Robocop for a high
extroverted picture Bill Clinton and for
the opposite a highly introverted
picture Obama for low neuroticism
pictured the dude from The Big Lebowski
or any stereotypical Californian and for
a high neuroticism picture Woody Allen
or Kanye West or most New Yorkers I
could pre associate about the big five
but I'll leave it there if you want more
then check out sambar Ennis's book and
Scott Barry Kaufman is also obsessed
with the big five and writes a bunch of
useful stuff about it there are two
other mental models that have greatly
influenced my thinking about people and
teams the first is Harvard professors
Robert Keegan's model of adult
development
Keegan argues that adults develop and
make sense of reality in five discrete
phases he lays out his theory in his
1994 book in over our heads which was
unfortunately not available on Kindle
but is available paperback and the title
in over our heads is a reference to how
the vast majority of adult Americans are
at the socialized stage of development
it's because of level-3 that have may
have difficulty taking other people's
perspectives and they tend to follow
assumptions given to them by society as
opposed to assumptions they freely
choose and he points out like in modern
life that many activities such as
parenting benefit if you can set
boundaries and not care what your kid
thinks need to direct them and doing
what you think they should do I feel
like I sometimes see well I imagine to
be socialized stage parents who are
afraid of they're almost afraid of their
kid on some level they they they take
what their kids think too seriously and
I want to be their friends first and
parents second there's when I'm
interviewing somebody there's something
that can feel a little bit icy when
you're interacting with self authored
people because they aren't sourcing
their approval from you
you can a there's something about the
tone of the interview that is
distinctive and to try to make this more
concrete there's this amazing example in
Chapter nine of in over our heads
where Keegan describes a couple who are
both operating for myself authored
mindset and it's a very distinctive
description of the way they make sense
of each other and of being married that
totally reminds me of one of Tim's
podcasts with Laird Hamilton and Gabby
Reece where Gabby is describing the way
she relates to Laird into their marriage
in a way that to my ear is super unusual
self authored way for people who are
interested in learning more about the
model
I recommend Keegan Slater book immunity
to change where he describes the model
briefly at the beginning of the book
I'll read a quick excerpt just so people
have a feel having a socialized mind
dramatically influences the sending and
receiving of information at work if this
is the level of mental complexity
through which I view the world then what
I send will be strongly influenced by
what I believe others want to hear let's
contrast this with a self authoring mind
if I view the world from this level of
mental complexity what I send is more
likely to be a function of what I deem
others need to hear to best further the
agenda or mission of my design
consciously or unconsciously I have a
direction and agenda a stance a strategy
and analysis of what is needed a prior
context from which my communication
arises the self authoring mind creates a
filter for what it will allow to come
through it places a priority on
receiving the information it is sought
information that I haven't asked for and
which does not have obvious relevance to
my own design for action has a much
tougher time making it through my filter
it's easy to see how all of this could
describe an admirable capacity for focus
for distinguishing the important from
the urgent for making best use of one's
limited time by having a means to cut
through the unending and ever mounting
claims on one's attention this speaks to
the way the self authoring mind is in
advanced over the socialized mind but
the same description may also be a
recipe for disaster if one's plan or
stance is flawed in some way if it
leaves out some crucial element of the
equation not appreciated by the filter
or if the world changes in such a way
that a once good frame becomes an
antiquated one contrast the self
transforming mind
both values and is wary about anyone
stance analysis or agenda it is mindful
that powerful though a given design
might be this design almost inevitably
leaves something out it is aware that it
lives in time and that the world is in
motion and that what might have made
sense today may not make as much sense
tomorrow
therefore when communicating people with
self transforming minds are not only
advancing their agenda in design they're
also inquiring about the design itself
information sending is not just on
behalf of driving it is also to remake
the map or reset the direction someone
wants to hear how a person sounds when
they make sense of reality at the self
transforming stage then I direct them to
listen to Tim's early podcast but edie
Catmull the Pixar founder and president
the loose but strong grip that Catmull
has on his own beliefs his fluid and
flexible relationship to time there's a
slightly ephemeral quality and comfort
with paradox that comes through in the
interview and he in the interview when
Tim's interview with him he's actually a
bit of a difficult interviewee and he
feels a little hard to pin down at times
for instance he refuses to answer Tim's
question about what he would tell his 20
year old self because he says now he has
a way of understanding that his 20 year
old self simply couldn't understand this
is all very consistent with a self
transforming mindset which happens later
in life for most people if it happens at
all it's an example it would surprise me
to hear Catmull say or think any version
of quote I'm just trying to stay
relevant as he gets older and from one
perspective you might be losing ground
versus a younger people in this industry
or he fails to get his phone calls
returned but his way of making sense is
likely that he gets to define who or
what is relevant not his peers in
Silicon Valley or in the movie industry
one last self-transforming example I
would give is the voice of the narrator
of the poem parable by Louise Gluck if
you google it she's really amazing the
third mental model that I find myself
recommending lately is not in a book but
on a slightly obscure website called
work with source calm and it's based on
a European management consultant who
studied hundreds of startups and
realized that even when there are
multiple co-founders there was actually
always in every case he found an axe
single-source the person who took the
first risk on a new initiative even if
that risk was only picking up the phone
and calling the other co-founder and he
argues that that source maintains a
unique relationship with the gestalt
when he calls the gestalt of the
original idea and has that person has an
intuitive knowledge of what the right
next step for the initiative is whereas
others who joined later to help with the
execution often lack that intuitive
connection to the founders original
insight and these guys argue that many
organizational tensions and power
struggles actually often revolve around
lack of explicit acknowledgment of who
the source of the initiative is I was
talking about this for the prominent
angel investor recently and he found
that consistent with his sample of
startups and he noted that many founders
seem to hire friends as co-founders more
to quell their own anxiety during the
early highly ambiguous days of a new
company than to fulfill a specific role
this can work fine as long as everyone
is clear on who the source is
there's and it's a little paradoxical
here is the the responsibility to fully
own the role of source rests in large
part with the source themselves handing
off the source role of an initiative to
another person is possible but extremely
difficult and it's often mishandled and
these guys note that a key to a
successful transition is for the
original source to actually move on and
allow the new leader room to move this I
was speaking with an investment manager
about this and he had it was consistent
with a study he'd done of stock
performance following founder CEOs
departing their businesses and he found
that any subsequent positive stock
performance was correlated with the
founder completely leaving the board
rather than hanging around to mentor the
next CEO so through that lens gates
remaining on the Microsoft board during
Ballmer's tenure may have contributed to
subsequent lackluster stock performance
and Ballmer's inability to kind of
excerpt his own creative vision whereas
Ballmer leaving the board has allowed
such an Nadella to fully assert his own
creative vision
encounter this dynamic myself sometimes
in running a multi-family office where
we manage money for Forbes 500 families
and second and third generations
sometimes struggle with how to relate to
the original patriarch and the quote
source of their wealth and it's my
observation it's often the
responsibility room for real transition
is in the hands of the original source
it's the lesson from George Washington's
song in the Hamilton musical as
Washington declines Hamilton's plea to
run for a third term and these things
we're gonna teach them how to say
goodbye
what purchase of $100 or less has most
positively impacted your life in the
last six months or in recent memory so I
recently bought the thinnest fi ni as
swim paddles they somewhat magically
lengthen out my freestyle stroke and
when I combined them with some fins I
used the ones from Cressy CR ESS I feel
sometimes like I'm almost flying through
the water for non swimmers I highly
recommend the canned sardines from
Matisse Madi's II I feel like one of my
proudest accomplishments as a dad is
that my two younger kids eat sardines
with me most mornings for breakfast
they're super high protein high good
fats there's no need to supplement fish
oil and Matiz sardines aren't fishy I
usually add avocado with salt and lemon
and the kids love them and I often
alternate the sardines with canned wild
salmon belly which they call roast rekha
re stre ca from the company vital choice
the bonus on both of those is that when
the zombie apocalypse comes you'll have
canned food ready to go how has a
failure or apparent failure set you up
for later success do you have any
favorite failure of yours I have so many
failures I'm just gonna pick one and my
role in in investing in and seeding
investment firms I do really extensive
reference checks on people in order to
try to accelerate the process of
building mutual trust with them and I
should note that I have a somewhat oddly
specific aspiration to be the best in
the world are among the best in the
world in terms of being able to really
do a reference on someone I feel like
it's a real art form
their private information in the form of
multiple perspectives about how someone
has played a repeat iteration game in
the past and then try to accurately
predict how they're gonna play in the
future I defined success as gathering
enough honest perspectives on someone to
mimic how I would know someone if I had
sat next to them at work for five years
we each truck we try to do references in
person and it's a huge time investment
in late 2007 I was about to back a firm
and we conducted a final reference check
with the investment managers former boss
who was quite negative and skeptical
about his former analyst I remember I
asked him what percentile the analyst
was in terms of all the analysts who had
ever worked for him and he said top 60%
wish I thought I'd misheard at first and
I've never gotten that response again in
a reference and it surprised me given
that the analyst had given me this guy's
name as a reference it wasn't an off
list reference it was an honest list and
it made me pause on proceeding with the
investment which then proceeded to work
out amazingly well as the financial
crisis unfolded I had a lot of regret
about the size of the profits I missed
later on in emerg of the reference
source may have had an agenda to
sabotage his former Protege a new firm
then several years later I was
evaluating another investment manager to
partner with and toward the end of our
diligence process I got another
reference not quite as negative that one
but it was mixed and but I felt like at
this point I was better able to hold
multiple perspectives simultaneously
without experiencing cognitive
dissonance it's like the state of
negative capability that Keats referred
to as useful to writers and this time
having those mixed data points only me
only made me do more work and I gained
even more conviction in the character
and competence of the investment manager
and that investment has ended up being
super profitable and I think absent my
earlier failure I wouldn't have had the
ability to see the reality of the
situation and it also just helped me
appreciate something I try to do which
is I try to hold people's perspectives
with a light grip which is the knowledge
that they and I have very incomplete
maps of reality what are bad
recommendations that you hear in your
profession or area of expertise so I
think people massively over use the term
hedge fund they fetishize it a little
too much it reminds me a little bit of a
similar issue that Ray Dalio fountain
when he used the word depression in 2008
to describe some of the underlying
dynamics in the economy he found that
his readers had too much baggage with
the word so he switched to using the
word deep process and you've all her re
makes a similar kind of reframing move
by referring to us as sapiens because
there's so much baggage about being
human and being in the scent you know
being in the center of the species but
the most important species in a similar
way I think people now have way too much
baggage where the word hedge-fund the
press and the managers themselves have
made it almost jumped the shark and I've
been telling people lately I think we
should start using H structure or
something like that instead capture the
concept of incentive compensation I
don't think it's useful to see a hedge
fund or a product or even the hedge fund
industry because these are just
temporary collections of flawed
brilliant people who in any given year
decided to make a sequel to the movie
they made the prior year the only
product is the set of future decisions
that the portfolio manager makes they
get divorced or depressed if they're
second-in-command leaves the quote
product completely changes and I think
thinking of it as a product ignores the
reality that the only source of
stability is actually whether the
mindset of the team leader is resilient
or even anti fragile which was the
Nassim Taleb thing about it actually
getting stronger with volatility rather
than just enduring it when you feel
overwhelmed or unfocused what do you do
so I asked myself what would be the
worst thing about that outcome not going
the way I want it actually started using
it out loud with my kids and we recently
might eat year old daughter started
asking it back to me which was karmic
full-circle I really like to be punctual
and we were late to drop her at school
and I was impatiently hurrying her along
and she asked me dad what exactly would
be the worst thing about being late and
in the moment it completely shifted my
mindset I like the question because it
often surfaces a hidden assumption in
this case maybe some up some conscious
script of I'm playing the role of father
and our family meets our commitments or
some version of that and another good
related question is Byron Katie's thing
about could the opposite of your story
be true I think that that question
serves the same role
in the last five years what new belief
behavior or habit has most improved your
life I've begun swimming most mornings
and I find it often shifts my mindset
for the entire rest of my day there are
some swimmers talk about this concept of
water feel which is getting a grip in
the water and pulling your body past
that point instead of ripping your hand
through the water living your hand
through the water moves you forward but
it's a lot less efficient and it's less
graceful and I really like David Foster
Wallace his speech this is water and
where he's making the point that so much
of water so much of life as water to us
we're swimming in it we can't see it
because we're either in a hurry or not
awake to our context or in Kian language
we are subject to it and when I stop to
really feel the water before I pull it
shifts my way of being from one of kind
of thrashing towards the end of the pool
somewhat mindlessly to a more effortless
flow of working with the reality of the
water where I am what advice would you
give to a smart driven college student
about to enter the real world so lately
I've been thinking about careers through
Dan Siegel's model of mental health
where he says picture a river flowing
between two banks where one side is
chaos and the other side is rigidity and
then points out that mental illness is
all reside on one bank or the other
schizophrenia is on the chaos side OCD
is rigidity and basically healthy
integration is swimming in the middle of
the river is his argument and most
college students have started life
closer to the rigidity bank is my
observation and over the course of their
careers will experiment with swimming
toward the middle and I've come to think
of the lane right next to rigidity the
rigidity bank as an appropriately
conventional one for what in your 20
when you're new 20s and you're kind of
acquiring the skill of refining reality
it's a place to swim where it's
important to learn the jargon of an
industry an apprentice under somebody to
develop judgment and discover your own
zone a genius and I think swimming in
the middle lane happens most often in
people's 30s or 40s it's a stage where
you begin crafting your own language for
what you do as an increasingly strong
poet you make
your craft your own you view your life
is more self-expression than simply
playing out other people's roles for you
and then some small percentage of people
will pedal over to the lane next to
chaos which is a place where you find
novelists like Robert Pierce ayg David
Foster Wallace investors like Mike burry
or Eddie Lampert or entrepreneurs like
Steve Jobs in Elon Musk and I
experienced them as consistently
asserting reality through through
powerful storytelling while always
bearing the risk that their egos grow
too big and they're creative narcissism
gets too well defended they lose
situational awareness and they basically
lose their feedback loop with reality I
visualize them almost flopping on to the
bank of chaos and so if you look at it
through this lens then per SIG's
wrestling with sanity towards the end of
his life Steve Jobs is magical thinking
about his illness and Eddie Lampert Ayn
Randian framing of his investment in
Sears may have all been examples of
these guys losing their feel for where
they can mythologize to the point of
bending our collective reality and then
they suddenly briefly appear crazy
I think musk in particular drives hedge
fund managers up the wall as half of
them are shortest shares because he
exudes so much promotional hucksterism
as he asserts reality and half of them
are long because he's actually thinking
on a hundred year timescale that's very
confusing
Eddie struck we always said that if you
want to have variant perception it helps
to be variant and I remember
interviewing Mike burry Steve Eisman and
all the other somewhat fringe somewhat
variant investors who were shorting
subprime mortgages in 2006 and all the
basically all the characters that
Michael Lewis captured so accurately in
the big short and the housing bubble is
obvious in retrospect but at the time
almost everyone thought they were
completely smoking dope and the current
crypto scene the cryptocurrency scene
reminds me a lot of the subprime short
ecosystem because the opportunity
attracts the most that were the more
variant players have nothing to lose
from disrupting the status quo so
encrypt you've got all the libertarians
and the unemployed macro hedge fund
managers and all the kids there's this
great quote by one of the characters in
Tom Stoppard's play Arcadia that the
crypto guys like which is the
future is disorder a door like this has
cracked open five or six times since we
got up on our hind legs
it's the best possible time to be alive
when almost everything you thought you
knew is wrong I think that mentality of
saying bring it on to chaos that now
that now is the best possible time to be
alive to quote learn to love the rain
this Josh Waitzkin says it's really hard
for people have succeeded in the status
quo context and so I think the you know
Bitcoin could just be a bubble due to QE
post the financial crisis or it could be
a change in how we organize human
activity at the level of the internet
itself or both and I'm at the moment
trying to hold both perspectives without
needing to decide yet trying to stay I
think of as an open chair instead of
striving for closure I'll finish up the
career question with one last quote from
the very self-transforming Charlie
Munger who at 93 has no filters left any
more wisdom per sentence than almost
anyone I read he says I've noticed in a
long lifetime that the people who really
love you are the people where you
scramble together with difficulty and
you've jointly gotten through and in the
end those people will love you more than
somebody who just shared in an even
prosperity through the whole thing so
this adversity that seems so awful when
you're scrambling through actually is
the cinah cure of your success your
affection every other damn thing the
idea that life is a series of
adversities and each one is an
opportunity to behave well instead of
badly is a very very good idea and he
says and it works so well in old age
because you get so many adversities you
can't fix so you better have some
technique for welcoming those
adversities hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and will you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favourite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by 99designs whether
you need a logo custom website app book
cover or anything else 99designs was
created to make great design accessible
to everyone that's you and to make the
process as easy as possible I've used 99
designs for years now I've used them for
book covers some mock-ups for the 4-hour
body which went on to become a number
one York Times best seller illustrations
of all different types for the
multi-volume The Tao of Seneca which you
can check out and other graphic design
projects for a long time out and I've
been very impressed by the quality of
their designers and illustrators and you
don't have to take my word for it you
should check out some of my projects at
99designs comm forward slash Tim I
really encourage you to take a look
because you will be impressed 99 designs
compote slash Tim van den Designs has
freelance experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the town of Seneca or you
can get concepts from multiple designers
and then pick your favorite so whether
you're starting a business or just
looking for an extra design help
resources etc 99designs
has a solution right now you guys my
listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade
on your first design to check out your
first free upgrade please visit 99
designs comm forward slash Tim and click
the link on the landing page you can
also find their samples of projects from
you guys listeners who use 99 designs
for logos apps even product packaging so
check it out 99 designs dot-com forward
slash Tim this episode is brought to you
by ascent
protein the cleanest least processed
protein I've ever consumed and I have
tried just about everything since well
before the 4-hour body I've started my
day with 20 to 30 grams of protein first
thing that has been part of my routine
but I don't always have the time or
necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal so what to do protein powders can
be a fast way to get this protein need
met but most products are full of crap
they're bleached in excess sugar
terrible artificial sweeteners or just
straightforward low-grade low quality
protein a scent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent company is
actually cheese manufacturers so that
they produce their own native proteins
it's it's really fascinating and I've
looked at their processing it takes or
it took to them about five years to
develop you can mix the protein in as
little as four ounces without any clumps
or issues of mix ability whatsoever and
they nailed the taste they tested it for
instance there's the chocolate version
two hundred and eighty two different
versions they put a lot of money and a
lot of time into R&D for this particular
product if you love coffee they also
have a brand new cappuccino flavor which
is a variation I've enjoyed if you
prefer to test something outside of the
traditional vanilla or chocolate and
they have both way and micellar casein
so if you want to say improve body
composition and recovery overnight
slow-release you can take the micellar
casein or in my case whey protein I
would take post-workout for instance or
in the morning so check it out these
guys are really fascinating visit ascent
protein dot-com folic / Tim that's a
scen TPR otti n.com a sense like first
ascent going up ascent protein complex /
Tim and you will receive 20% off your
entire purchase if you want a very quick
20 to 30 gram dose to start your day or
after workout this is a fantastic option
it is arguably the best that I found so
again check it out ascent protein comm
forward slash 10
[Applause]
you